hey Vsauce Michael here and I'm in Los
Angeles but today we're going to talk
about love you can't buy love but what
if you could I mean what if I had a
machine that could make you fall in love
with someone for the rest of your life
what should I charge for the use of that
machine well we should first of all be
clear about what we mean when we say
love I'm not talking about the love you
have for your BFFs or your love for your
family or your love of learning I'm also
not talking about lust an immediate
attraction we have towards other people
mediated by hormones like testosterone
and estrogen I'm talking about what
happens later when you begin to
associate an immediate reward with one
other person what we call the hash in it
love this is what you see in new couples
where they want to be with each other
and they're almost obsessed with each
other well psychologists have a really
great term for that kind of love they
call it limerence that's right whenever
you are in this state and you do things
like wake up super early to get a bagel
with a person and even though you're
gonna miss class just because you want
to see them that badly you're exhibiting
limb rent behavior okay that sounds
great but if I want to sell love I'm
gonna have to find a way to measure it
and it turns out to be quite a difficult
task we do have a tool called the
passionate love survey was developed by
psychologists and it's been found to be
quite reliable when it comes to
analyzing other behaviors we associate
with passionate love for instance we
found using the survey that men and
women both experienced the same amounts
of passionate love when they're in a
relationship we've also found that men
tend to fall into love faster and sooner
than women who appear to be more
cautious but we're here to talk about
money interesting a UK study once looked
at people who heard that someone else
loved them they heard the phrase I love
you for the first time and they took the
amount of happiness those people felt
and compared it to the amount of
happiness gamblers feel when they win
large sums of money their conclusion
that hearing that someone loves you for
the first time is the equivalent happy
level of receiving $267,000 but when you
go beyond passionate love to committed
long-term love there's all kinds of
practical benefits marriage brings in
fact it's been estimated that tax breaks
and health care costs altogether mean
that being married is the equivalent of
receiving an extra $100,000 a year now
we have a lot of ways of visualizing the
effect having money has on a person for
instance we know that in wealthier
countries people report feeling respect
more often they also report eating
tastier foods for instance but here's
what's really awesome take a look at the
graph of wealth against love it doesn't
matter
love is democratic no matter who you are
how much money you have people all over
the world are feeling it it should be
noted that having more money does not
necessarily equate to being more happy
this is what's known as the hedonistic
treadmill getting more money helps with
happiness but only up to a certain point
in the United States that point is about
seventy five thousand dollars a year at
that point more money has diminishing
returns on how happy it makes you
another thing that correlates to having
more money more wealth is living longer
having the larger life expectancy but
you know what else correlates to living
longer love but not just passionate love
the kind of love that follows it
committed long-term love in fact people
who form lifelong pair bonds with
another person live on average 15%
longer so if you want to be really non
hard sciency about it all other things
being equal and assuming that you're not
already super super rich finding a pair
bond finding a relationship that lasts
for life is the equivalent of making
about an extra thirty to forty thousand
dollars a year now like I said that's
not hard science but you know what is
vasopressin and oxytocin the chemicals
that are exuded in people's brains when
they look at photos of people that they
formed committed
long-term relationships with these
chemicals are incredible we've also seen
elevated levels of them in dogs that
have been pet for a really long time and
we also know that couples who receive
high levels of these chemicals resolve
conflicts faster and people who struggle
to produce these chemicals in their
brain have a similar struggle when it
comes to forming long-term relationships
in fact you can raise your levels of
oxytocin or vasopressin inside your own
brain by simply looking into someone
else's eyes that's right
so in a way looking into the eyes of
somebody that you like is the
administration of a psychoactive drug
that's addictive and the long-term
consequences are living longer thanks
for watching
[Music]